once kit culen had a family of his own
he needed money his neighbor was a stage
manager at The Ensemble Studio Theater
who needed a child actor and McColly was
the right age and gender for the job and
he was essentially too young to say no
he latched on to this thing with McColly
and took it for all it was worth while
filming The Good Son in 1993 a
12-year-old mcau decided that he needed
a break as he recalled to New York
Magazine I just said to Kit listen I'm
really getting tired and I'm not at
school as much as I'd like to be I
really need some time off he said yeah
sure and the next thing I knew I was on
the next set doing the next thing and it
just kind of clicked in my brain okay
there's basically nothing I can do to
make this stop the following year mcau
decided to quit acting